there's a medical movement going viral
called medical gaslighting where women
are made to feel less than when they
bring up certain health issues and i
think a lot of us can relate to this and
today we are working with ollie and
joining me to talk about women's health
topics that should have no apologies
about them is dr taz
hi dr taz hi drew thank you for having
me thank you for doing this first of all
i am an ollie customer it's what i give
to my kids i am a huge ali fan it really
spoke to me and i would love to know
why do you think that women's health
concerns and issues and questions get
shrugged off well drew this is an issue
and this is you know gaslighting is real
and i think what's happening is for a
long time women's health issues have
been swept under the rug they've been
told it's normal it's in their head you
know it's a part of the aging process
and there are many reasons for that but
i think as women we have to advocate for
ourselves and we really have to try to
find answers even when we're being
dismissed do you think that there is
something that we can do about it
absolutely well awareness is everything
right you and i are talking about it
today i think that's important but i
would say to every woman out there first
of all get educated really understand
their issue make a list of questions get
second opinions don't be shy to do that
and don't accept no for an answer you
know i think that's really important as
well like go after the information that
you need to get better there's one brand
ali that's really getting behind the
movement ollie's starting a movement of
unapologetic confidence really aiming to
spark dialogue around many of these
health topics that women face including
low libido normal hormone shifts and
even gas and bloating that are often
associated many times with food and
period swings i am your key demo and
i'm really excited because i see this
supplement bottle right here
beat the bloat absolutely ali offers
self-care solutions that really help to
normalize these topics that women are
facing today what do we do you know
there are answers so here's what you can
do start with your diet food is medicine
remember really increasing the amount of
plant-based foods you're getting in
getting the fiber in decreasing refined
sugar and carbohydrates all of those are
going to help to really bring gas and
bloating down using digestive enzymes so
don't order nachos tonight at midnight
when i get home from a party no and i'm
curious like why is this sort of
inflammation and gas and bloating why is
it always so dismissed and how can we
kind of
target the questions
to medical professionals as a woman
you really want to be your own best
advocate you want to really have a list
together go after your questions make
sure you get the answers for them and
don't accept no for an answer so this
conversation is vital for me i hope it
reaches other people out there and i
really took from you my takeaway is do
not accept no for an answer absolutely
get multiple opinions and really be your
own advocate yeah be really strong yes
don't and have no shame i am a big ali
fan and i'm really glad that you are
advocating for women to advocate for
themselves thank you thank you
you're welcome
[Music]